i spent my entire adult life
trying to help people
give of myself and i can't even get my
medical bill paid
well john phil got my medical bill paid
he finally got these politicians with
his team firefighter ray pfeiffer who
has since died fought
with terminal cancer for nine years in a
wheelchair
literally at the end came out of hospice
to go
finalize
getting us this coverage
detective luis alvarez who testified
days before he died in front of congress
and
a bunch of other guys that were really
really sick and we had to shame these
people into signing on and luckily we
had jon stewart come on and literally
just just hound these guys and and shame
them and embarrass them
and what it all stemmed from was in 2006
the first
of death that was determined to be
linked to 9 11 there was others but the
first one that was officially linked
was a new york city police detective who
initially the city said he died of
advanced lung disease his lungs were
protruding out of his body and he was on
painkillers and it was so bad at the end
that the doctors said just grind them up
snort them drink it whatever you need to
do to get instant relief
so when they found the talcum from the
pill lining in his lungs they said oh no
this is opiate abuse you didn't he
didn't die of lung disease so they said
and the mayor was quoted as saying he is
not a hero
well shame on you mr mayor he was a hero
and his father who was a retired police
chief
married up with the feel good foundation
and jon stewart
and ray pfeiffer
detective alvarez
and they got us all covered
but it took so long lex it was so
heartbreaking these people who were
lining up three deep politicians three
deep to catch a picture with a responder
so they can tweet
never forget and hashtag look at me and
hey how am i doing all that bullcrap but
they didn't know they were nowhere to be
freaking found i phys i i literally
witnessed them hiding in cloak rooms
running down hallways away from us those
freaking cowards that's cowardice
can i just linger on the jon stewart
thing the comedian actor jon stewart
his testimony before congress over the
benefits for 9 11 first responders
i mean there's a lot of important human
beings in this story but he has a big
voice
and he spoke from the heart what do you
make of that testimony
oh it was heartfelt i mean
he spoke look i mean john john was a
you know a polarizing guy right there's
certain things like over the years he
was cutting edge and i might not have
agreed with all of his
oh yeah you know well you know some
stuff i'm not right you know like we all
but but i tell you i found him as funny
i i enjoyed his humor
i would love the two you'd have a
conversation no but but again i love a
guy where you can have you can have a
difference in opinions that's the
beautiful thing about the firehouse
kitchen i mean it could get raucous and
now i don't know it's a little different
situation but i mean back in the day
some funny stuff but yeah john john
literally just took his talents
you would think he was speaking from the
heart of a fireman or a cop or a soldier
or a marine or you know someone who was
there
but i think he
especially got to know ray so well and
ray had this stack of mass cards from
you know the funeral cards they give out
it looks like you know a larger business
card that's laminated
and ray had a stack of them he would
carry around i think it was close to 100
cards and john saw it he said what's
that
he says these are my cards he said for
what he says for my brother's funerals
he was like oh my god you've been to
that many funerals
he goes yeah this is just the the ones i
made like like you know
and john i think was was just stunned
and like john actually had that stack of
cards after after ray passed and like
said look this look at these look
there's to be more of these cards
we have one guy a week or girl one one
responder or recovery worker or someone
who actually resided down there
there's more than one a week dying
it's one a day dying
on average and on average two people are
diagnosed with a 9 11 cancer or
disease right now this the worst part is
there's autoimmune diseases flying off
the graph
and they're not covered under
legislation by the grace of god my
cancer is covered if my if my cancer
comes back i mean i'm in remission it's
technically incurable but i'm i've been
blessed i'm staying ahead of this stuff
going on 10 years
but if it comes back with a vengeance
tomorrow and takes me you know at least
my my wife will get my pension and be
able to live her life without fear
but my friends who are suffering from
these advanced autoimmunes their wives
get nothing their pension dies with them
and
we're hoping that that you know john and
his army can can
shame these politicians once again
to have the kindness and decency to
cover these autoimmunes
you know
they're throwing a lot of money around
on a lot of things lately and
this is one that they won't and and
these are lives in the balance who
really need it and john had this strong
line
they did their jobs
do yours
talking to the politicians yeah
and it it
it's a strong wake-up call that
um it's not about the twitter or the
social media or all that kind of stuff
it's you have a job to do and you have
to
it's that compassion
uh implemented in form of money of
helping people oh yeah that were there
for you when you needed help well we had
a guy i mean i might get audited out of
this one but i hope not but
we had a congressman from out west i
won't say where but he prided himself on
saying he was a retired cop yeah
busy cop
22 years yeah he said no on the
legislation
i witnessed the cop who was dying get
out of his wheelchair and said hey
brother
i got a half a million dollars in
medical bills and i'm a short timer i
got a few months to live who the f is
gonna pay him do the right thing you say
you're a cop you show me you're a cop
and you sign that paper and the guy
started tearing up the congressman and
he signed it but he had to be freaking
shamed and you know what he said well
this doesn't really confront me this is
pork as far as my district's concerned
he goes oh yeah do you know there's 10
guys from your district who came across
the country to help us that are also
dying he had no idea yeah he had no idea
and that's the sad part about alex
there's there's
it's a failure in leadership
you know
i mean i think some people would vote
for mickey mouse just because if he ran
i mean no offense against mickey mouse i
like him he's a good guy right i mean
but like like allegedly allegedly
supposedly yeah yeah you know but
seriously like
i i he i look at i look at some of the
leadership sometimes and go
we're in trouble and also you lose uh i
think the way government is structured
is
um people who are senators or um
people
who are in congress they
they start playing a game between each
other and they lose track of the
connection to the to the to the people
to basic humanity so you forget even
when you think of yourself as a cop
uh you forget what are like the cops and
the the other people
uh servicing the community actually
experiencing all the the troubles
they're going through and how they can
actually be helped because you lose
touch that because you're not actually
living you're not talking to them you're
not living among them and i mean that's
a natural part of the system but i think
that's why character and great
leadership is important is you say
you leave the game of congress and you
go back to the people um i mean that's
what
the the country you know it's like the
george washington ideal is you're not
playing a game of power
you ultimately see yourself as somebody
who's servicing this country service in
the community and that requires talking
to the people
in their time of hardship
you